well details are still emerging
about this attack uh police sources
though have confirmed
that they shot an attacker dead he had
killed an individual and we understand
from police sources that that man
was a middle school teacher and that the
attack happened very close to a school
now
one of the areas where there are
conflicting reports is that
uh some police sources said that the
man's throat was slit
um other local sources are saying that
the man was
decapitated but we're waiting for
absolute uh confirmation
on that from the police at this stage
but the police hat or france has
launched an anti-terror investigation
the anti-terrorism
prosecutor has been called in we also
have heard in the last few minutes that
the interior minister
has returned or is returning urgently uh
to paris now there were also suggestions
from local sources
um that the man shouted allah akbar or
god is great
when he was carrying out the attack i
have to say that a police spokesman is
saying
that is being investigated at this stage
uh it hasn't been uh confirmed but as i
say
being treated for now but as an uh
terrorism attack
uh investigating the matter further but
one man we're told
a middle school teacher was killed and
then the police moved in
and shot the attacker okay michelle
thank you